kerry 54 ans a arrêté l'école à 14 ans
il ne sait pas écrire à peine lire et
pourtant il est devenu le patron du luna
park à deux semaines de l'ouverture
pierrick va remettre en service ces deux
camionnettes publicitaires qu'il a
lui-même customiser bollaert et toutes
les soirées et après la musique par
l'ouvrir
les amicalistes me lafforgue rochelle
une estafette qui n'est pas du goût de
tout le monde alors celle de voiture le
voilà l'été je ne lui dit pas si les
voir l'avenir
normal en effet elle a promené son dos
elle prendre les yeux il axe portrait
pourtant le son le mais parfois on
essaie d'être d'être respectueux mais
forcément il a toujours dit
du soir au matin les voiturettes de
pierrick sillonnent les rues du cap
d'agde la route des plages et les
campings depuis 20 ans le luna park et
le royaume de pierrick il possède une
dizaine de manèges mais surtout le
terrain du parc
ils louent des emplacements aux autres
forains pour qu'ils y installent leurs
attractions
un seigneur il est là depuis quelques
années il a été rénové
29 c'est un très beau manège et c'est
vraiment pour les kamikazes-- le défi du
patron présenter à chaque ouverture des
manèges toujours plus spectaculaires et
pour que les clients reviennent
pierrick mise sur une attraction phare
l'apocalypse il a économisé pendant cinq
ans sur les recettes du parc pour
acheter d'occasion cette folie à 500000
euros
c'est la rolls des g 8
il est mossoul parce que j'ai quand même
1 km de circuit il fait partie fait
partie m 6000 mètres carrés l'heureuse
lui tout seul il est il est énorme
tu est énorme c'est pierrick tiens à ce
que chaque manège fonctionne
parfaitement
c'est aussi parce que le luna park est
un héritage familial
le joyau de son clan
paul son père aujourd'hui âgé de 79 ans
installée ici les premiers carrousel en
à cette époque la station balnéaire du
cap d'agde est en pleine expansion
ça a été très dur au début c'étaient des
mariages était rien de fait linea et
écrire ils ont fait venir l'eau c'était
je te dirai pas une paille des maisons
et variés ya pas eu nos boîtes à mériel
et à mesure ça se construit autour je te
le pionner un pionnier qui a créé une
dynastie de forains dont l'héritier n'a
que 19 ans preston est le petit fils de
paul saffo vérifier que l'argent est le
fils de pierrick system sas en péril la
donner pour commencer hier entre en
espérant avec ça de pouvoir acheter
d'autres manèges pouvoir investir tous
les cas la jeanne le saut chez les
forains l'accoutumée d'offrir un manège
à son fils pour ses 18 ans un cadeau qui
se mérite
les patriarches forains veille au grain
pour assurer la pérennité de la sphère
familiale vos débuts en fête ou un moule
on fait tenir pour m'apprendre parce
qu'ils peuvent en donner manager si je
ne le savent pas ce que je vais faire de
mon argent si j'ai pas l'âge et le gérer
leurs preuves faut faire ses preuves
gratuit et après quand tu vois que tu es
capable de réussir ton argent comme tu
veux il est quand même derrière parce
qu'il sait que si c'est comme on veut
nous c'est n'importe quoi non pas
jusqu'à 20 ans il s'est battu pour voir
tout ce qu'il a eu
mais nous on vous a tout donné donc
c'est pas pareil
reston ne se déplace jamais sans son
cousin pierce à 19 ans les deux jeunes
forains serait temps futur patron du
parc familial
mais ils savent qu'ils doivent d'abord
faire leurs preuves pendant la saison
estivale
ça fait tellement je vois mon père que
je t'aime bien mon manège fait remonter
le plus possible de personnes dans mon
manège de faire la meilleure saison
possible pour preston premier verdict
dans quelques heures
lors de la soirée d'ouverture du luna
park
[Musique]
preston le fils de pierrick la base du
métier de forain s'est harangué la foule
avec son micro
preston vient d'être prise en défaut et
à ce moment là mon père pas ça tout le
temps
c'est malheureux mais c'est pas de
chance il passe quand je parle pas donc
après une fois qu'il est passé mais
j'aimerais v8 j'étais fatigué sur le
stand voisin le cousin de preston pierre
semble lui bien s'en sortir
il a attiré une cinquantaine de
personnes autour de lui son attraction
c'est l'échelle 1 je m'adresse grand
classique des fêtes foraines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pierce a réalisé l'ascension en quelques
secondes
en apparence aucune difficulté mais
lorsqu'un client tente sa chance
le résultat est toujours le même un
échec
expéditif
le secret de la réussite d un jeu rage
demande bronx lausanne c'est possible et
non laisser la chance trois décès et si
le futur champion le futur gagnant ce
jeu illustre bien à quel point les
forains sont astucieux car le secret
c'est un savant mélange d'équilibré et
de placement et il faut tout de même de
l'entraînement pour pousser les clients
à acheter leurs tickets à 4 euros
la technique de pire c'est simple mais
redoutable faire la démonstration à la
foule que même un enfant petit parvenir
mais ce que les gens ne savent pas c'est
que ce jeune homme est fort ans
[Musique]
en faisant plus d'une centaine de
clients pierce en poche presque 500
euros chaque soir en moyenne
[Musique]